[Music]
three
two one action what up guys welcome back
to off the record where we talk about
whatever we want and today's segment is
ask an expert and we have kevin the real
estate agent here
i have one question i wrote it down
because it's kind of complicated okay
but i always hear the concept of people
uh buying a house
yeah it goes up in value yeah and then
now there's this thing called equity
right yeah and then with equity they're
able to either buy
a new home or remodel their home
correct um so in essence it's like a
loan to yourself right
kind of you will end up getting a loan
because it's not a free
it's not free money so how does that all
of that work
so in essence what happens is when you
start to build equity there's a couple
ways you can build equity home prices go
up
you can build equity from the time you
purchase the property
to whatever the current market rate is
yeah um
the other way you can build equity is
you know every month that you're paying
towards your mortgage payment
it's bringing the principal down right
so then you build equity that way as
well too
uh but what you were talking about can
you pull money out
to let's say go purchase another
property or remodel
basically you would go back to the bank
right because you say okay i bought the
house for
a million dollars it's now worth 1.2
can i take this extra 200 000 and
yeah i want to do some improvements to
it you are actually technically and
probably talk to a loan officer they're
probably more expert on this but you are
whenever you're pulling money out it's
supposed to go
back into the property right you're not
supposed to pull the money out and go
buy a car
right people do that but you're not
supposed to because
remember the bank is giving you money
based off of the house itself
i see so but yeah you can pull the money
out and i mean
when you say pull the money out yeah is
that in the form of another loan or
it will be informative so you get
another is that when you refinance
you refine it well you there's a couple
different ways with refinance refinances
let's say your balance is you know half
a million dollars
you can refinance just a half a million
at whatever the interest rate is at that
time so if it's
i mean typically you only want to
refinance if it's lower
which is why a lot of people are doing
that to save money like right now right
right now low interest rates with the
low interest rates that's what
everybody's doing just to save money
just did it
it's beautiful how much did you save two
and a half percent
uh but mortgage payment wise how much
did oh my god it's like a thousand
there you go wow right you think about
it it's 12.
that's 12 000 within one year that you
could save that could go towards
something else
dude i started saving 3 000 a month
because i switched not to geico
to the garage that just popped in all of
our heads though i know that's how good
advertising
yeah but we uh we switched i switched
from uh uh i had a you know
a home to myself that i was renting it
was like
4 000 but if you add like everything
else that goes with it utilities
you know [ __ ] lawn guy whatever right
it was way over 4 000 but now
i live in my buddy's garage for 1200
bucks utilities included
the dream it is an adu but i prefer
garage because it
sounds french to me um
more fancier yeah and it's
i'm like man i get pretty much 3 000
plus a month yeah and i'm like dude this
is the best
and i get to buy all these toys and fun
stuff yeah
it's great but if i could refi and do
that too if i owned a house
that's even better yeah why why
shouldn't somebody buy
a house well that's where i look at a
lot of people are always like
kevin when's the market going to crash i
don't think anybody can really predict
when it's going to happen
is it it sounds like a chinese person
saying
i want to buy a house all the time
and i'm like it sometime it will happen
right but who knows
but for especially in l.a right i can't
speak for
other other states or other like cities
um la typically will maintain its value
pretty well just because we are
a international destination point right
so will our prices decrease in half in
value i think that's very
highly unlikely right but if you talk
about actual what's
what's more important right like either
the price tag that you look at or the
monthly payment that you pay
right a lot of people it's really the
monthly payment that you pay
so that affects your day-to-day because
that's yeah exactly because that's what
you have to fork out
it's irrelevant almost to a point with
with the actual pricing itself
and because interest rates have come so
low it has made everything much more
affordable now will interest rates stay
at this rate
i doubt it right i mean we're at two and
a half two point seven five that's
money dude yeah literally free money
right
i mean if inflation happens the the
banks are losing money yeah right on
these loans
so i always say if you really calculate
everything
like if prices come down interest rates
are probably going to go up
i can't predict when that or what that
interest rate is actually going to
be but it's probably gonna be a lot
higher than what we're paying now like
when i first started in the business in
2005
5.75 was the interest rate and was that
considered good
that was like extremely low because if
you go back into the 80s they're
they're in the teens right 13 14 15
maybe even some 18 19
uh was the interest rate so looking at
5.75 that was like
unheard of but they could afford a back
then because maybe the house was like
100 grand correct
yeah but now as like the rates keep
going lower and lower if you
really look at how much you're gonna pay
to the bank over a 30-year period
it's like a fraction of what it would be
even if the interest rates went up one
percent right
so i always look at from that point of
view because people are always like well
prices are getting too high well then it
looks
what is your objective with the house
right if you're gonna stay there for two
years then i would probably say
yeah don't do it because you're most
likely going to lose out
on you know equity in the house right
it's typically going to take you
anywhere between five to seven years
to hit like a break-even point for most
people right you can time a market
really good sometimes but
just going back off of historical
averages right but right now if you look
at just the rates and how much you would
save over a 30-year period it's
it's nuts so you would tell your mom to
buy right now i would
nice yeah i'd be like buy two really
hell yeah
free money out there free money yeah i
would buy a
a bunch if i could yeah because like uh
in vegas like you know they're also
way more affordable so i think for me my
plan is once i secure my mortgage
the one because that one is a little bit
higher i don't want to
like affect my credit score because
they'll affect the rates yeah once i
secure that one
then i'll be a lot more aggressive and
looking for the next home
correct i mean like in vegas it makes
sense when you like
pencil things out over here it's a
little bit more difficult i think it's
it's it's always a trade right
especially with the investment
properties are you looking more for cash
flow are you looking for appreciation
over time
over here in california and la i mean
appreciation is what
what makes it we get no cash flow off of
majority of the properties that
that you buy over there you might get
both right because
even when we were looking at those
smaller houses out there i asked tina to
run the numbers i'm like how much can
you get for rent
i mean even by putting twenty percent
down you can cover up
over here twenty percent down you'll
know you're out of pocket
like every month do you trust bart
because he told you that he was gonna be
in his forever home and then now you're
still working with him
do you find him reliable so he already
bought two houses and is not a reliable
customer
life always changes things happen right
so
yeah i trust like when you're walking
away from bart after
giving a sucker are you like i'll be
seeing this [ __ ]
again after biggs it's like
yeah uh yeah i think there was a
possibility that they were probably
gonna move one more time
yeah yeah yeah life changes because even
the first house the monterey park house
our plan was to stay there maybe like
five or six years
before we buy the forever home and the
minute we had taika
family starts coming over what we
thought was like the perfect space it
was just jam-packed
all the time and i'm like oh [ __ ] this
is crazy
so we needed a bigger space for family
to come over and then we end up getting
this house
yeah yeah i mean that's just how how
life is right we plan it one way and it
goes another way same thing with
business i just don't call anything
forever if i don't mean it that's just
my that's just
my personal opinion
steve would have been a way better
customer yeah i think so we'll talk
all right so when you okay you pull the
money out for equity
uh that's in the form is it now do you
have two loans or it's just
another loan but you have cash on hand
so there's a couple of different ways
that you could do it they call it cash
out refi
right so maybe you can lump it all up
where you have a portion
and then you just take out a specific
amount for cash
you can even do it in a form of what we
call line of credit right so if you have
enough equity you don't have to go
through the full process they'll just
look okay
your house you bought it for like 500
000 it's worth a million now and your
loan is only 200 000. we'll give you
another 100 000 on top
right so what does it look like like in
real life is it like let's say
my house is a million right and then it
went up to 1.2 like you said
so if i want to pull out the 200 do they
deposit the 200 into like another bank
account and then now my
mortgage is no longer on the million
it's on the 1.2
is that what it looks like you would
basically pay off that
original loan and then you would get
that new loan with that extra money on
it
so it still becomes one loan but it's a
brand new loan
yeah i see uh and then the cash you can
take out
right but your payments also could
change yeah well depending of how the
interest rate changes
right you could use the cash for
anything you technically can
technically don't tell this guy that
yeah i use it on crypto
this episode of off the record is
brought to you by
upstart so when i was going into college
like this is one of the
things i have on my credit score was um
back then i would see all these like
zero percent apr credit cards right and
i'm like cool i
here when you need to build your credit
you should have like multiple credit
cards open so i got like two or three of
them
the thing is with those zero percent
aprs after a certain time sometimes six
months sometimes a year
they all jump back to the immediate rate
and so i
i forgot and i bought a couple of things
and they all jumped up to like 20
and when it gets to 20 and it's
compounding it
it the money can grow really really fast
one of them ended up going to
collections because i wasn't really
working that much during college
you you were paying your debts i wasn't
so like this would have been really
helpful
because i could have consolidated all of
that credit card debt into one and then
just pay one payment
and when you're in college or you know
you have all these classes you're
worried about it's
your brain scattered all over the place
so when you have too many things to
focus on
it's really really hard so i'm really
glad that upstart exists because it
could help all the people now
and it's a fast and easy way to get a
personal loan to pay off your debt
all online and whether it's paying off
your credit cards like bart over here
or you just want to consolidate some
high interest debt
like me or funding just personal
expenses
or you know whatever it is over half a
million people have used upstart to get
a simple
fixed monthly payment upstart finds
smarter rates with
trusted partners because they assess
more than just your credit score
i think this is the main thing that's
super important so with a five-minute
online rate check you can see your rate
up front
for loans from 1 000 to get this 50
000 baby you can get approved the same
day
and receive funds as fast as one
business day
if debt is taking over your life it's
time to get a fresh start with
upstart so find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments today when
you go to upstart.com
off the record that's upstart.com off
the record
don't forget to use our url to let them
know we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application go to
upstart.com
off the record crypto's hot right now
dude sure
i don't know everyone's like you should
get real estate and i'm like it's too
slow
[Laughter]
it's two for sure it doesn't go 30 a day
yeah i want the swings man i want to
like win
grand and then the next second lose 200.
it feels good
yeah doesn't it and then you're just
waiting for a week watching it
obsessively
i'm like i hope it goes back up and it
goes back up and you're like who
i forgot about the pain i've been
looking at i think krypto for like 60
to 90 days straight now every single day
yeah
dude i love our text chains about it
this shit's amazing
but what's the cause for it to go like
up and down like it's just all
speculation it's all speculation man but
like why would one day go up like
it was at 40 and then it drops to like
35. it's informed speculation
sometimes you you hear things or like
there's there's some [ __ ]
article that comes out in cointelegraph
and they lie about bitcoin and then
bitcoin
drops and then it goes right back up the
next day it's hella volatile man oh yeah
for sure yeah
i see it i have a friend that says a lot
of it's actually really orchestrated
so he's like if you watch the players in
the game it's like this giant theater
that so you'll have like an
article that comes out right people go
oh no so they dump
right they dump all the all the bitcoin
back out and then you see
giant institutions come in it's almost
like perfect timing
and so it's like did these institutions
tell these guys to write this so that
the regular people can let it so there's
a lot of it's very like it's very
orchestrated but
do the institutions sell it afterwards
no they're holding on holding on
everyone has bot is holding on right now
that's why it's still like in the 30 000
right yeah
which i predicted but that's fine
you know so since you've been in real
estate for how long now
over 15 years april is going to be my
16. oh [ __ ] yeah
so in 16 years and you learn so much
along the way
is there anything that you would like
that you would say oh man i wish someone
would have told me this sooner or
later about this sooner about real
estate like actually being an agent
just anything or even just about the
industry um
like for me um i wish someone would have
told me
when your kid like your first home
should get be a beater home
because your kid's gonna beat it out
yeah when you're a kid it's like between
like two and four he's gonna [ __ ] [ __ ]
up
it was like crayon yeah like all the
markings in our current house right now
yeah they're all at like the two foot
range
there's [ __ ] soccer ball marks
there's like this tricycle slamming into
the wall
like i wish someone would have told me
that then i would be like okay cool like
my first time i'll just live in for the
next five years
because then the kid's gonna beat it up
like is there any like
i think in terms of investing the sooner
you can get in the better it's always
going to be
right the sooner yeah i think we live
especially in the world that we live in
today
like we're all about this what can we
buy where can we go
type of thing and i mean they're they're
cool and all but
like building wealth the easiest way is
i feel through real estate it's the most
conservative way to get so is there a
difference between
an event and a investment property and
owning your own home
because one can be an asset and one can
be a liability depending on your
situation right
yeah yeah um the investment isn't meant
for
everybody right because there there are
responsibilities that come with it
there's also risks that come with it so
you know some people are very risk
averse so i probably wouldn't say do
that but
for the majority of people i mean we all
need a roof over our head
right so to be able to fixate your cost
at a certain point
i think is always a good thing right
because if not i mean if inflation hits
which i predict right just how you think
crypto may go up to what was it 200 000
bitcoin 200 000 each i think they're
printing way too much [ __ ] money
right now i don't think people are going
right so
inflation hits rent's gonna skyrocket
right i think we've been okay with the
way
rents have been but depending on where
you live in the country as well too i
mean california has always been super
expensive
but if you can fixate your cost i think
that's like 30 years yeah for 30 years i
mean you don't have to move we always
want to move we want to upgrade
i think that's how life works right but
we don't have to
i mean we can probably work within our
means as well too
um but at least you have that going for
you you know um as opposed to hey you
could change
you can move from one location to
another location some people are nomadic
so
it's really depending on on your
lifestyle i've always wanted an expert
in here so i could ask him very a couple
very stupid things as well
yeah um has anyone ever paid for a house
in cash
like physically with a [ __ ] briefcase
you wouldn't be able to do that now
there's even no track if you pay cash
um i haven't had that experience i've
heard way back in the days yeah
here in monterey park people were like
here's the briefcase candy's restaurant
cash
probably yeah the soy sauce now
everything's gotta go through
through uh a wire transfer into into
escrow so
so you don't hear that sound anymore no
the attachy case
i got i got another question too there
which race is the hardest to work with
i'm just kidding
or religion or religion everybody
is you know their own special way
so sad to that
dude what's crazy is um back then drug
dealers and all these like tax evaders
would be able to buy at
full on cash and i'm like how did they
even get
that through it's so crazy right yeah
because um
when i hear cash payments obviously
they're wired
but that means people actually have that
kind of money in their bank account
correct with all those zeros and they're
like yeah but i mean there's still like
fraud schemes out there
you know with people you know swindling
money and still purchasing properties
and stuff like that they do have like
protocols like
these cash deals over a certain amount
they'll do background checks even after
it closes right they report it
and then they'll be like well let's
let's investigate this one like where it
came from
yeah exactly so as a well you're not a
loan officer but
when you do you ever see like your
clients financials to make sure that
when
during the whole process or is it just
the loan guys that see it i
i usually separate it right because i as
long as
i work with the trusted advisor on the
loan side i mean because there's guys
where i can be like hey just write me
this
and they'll be like sure but at the same
time i'm wasting my time if it doesn't
go through
right time is valuable for everybody we
can only do so much within a 24-hour
period i don't get any
more hours than you guys do right um
so i just trust that individual to do
their job i see right so i don't need to
see any of the financials i
i don't need to see how much you make or
how much money i mean the money how much
money you have to put down
i do because we do submit that with the
offer but in terms of like your
your tax returns and stuff like that i
don't know that's all the loan people do
you ever
do you ever go into a house and you and
you're like oh you know what
i think i'm gonna keep i'm gonna get
this one myself yesterday
to be honest
it was literally one of those things
where i was like
it's a three unit in in alhambra and i
showed it to one of my clients
remember google that three unit i'll
handle it we can beat them we can sneak
the price point is already like really
high but the the the person that
bought the property redid the whole
thing and it looks like amazing
and i had a couple of the guys on my
team like run the numbers i'm like what
do you guys
like okay what they're publishing is
this really true because i was like okay
if i could save some money then maybe i
could just go
sacrifice for a few years and just go
buy something sicker
um and the numbers really just like pan
out
right i think you'll be in the green as
soon as you buy it is that what you mean
well
so i think what what happened there's
this pretty cool top floor unit
um and then they have two down surgeries
so the top floor is a two bedroom two
bath
and it was like 1400 square feet the
bottom there's a three bedroom one bath
and then there's also a two bedroom one
bath
because it was so well done like you're
gonna get premium rent on it so
for me to just instead i could go either
go buy a house and put all my money down
on
a new house or can i buy this one
and really like the rent that i would
collect on the two units downstairs
all i would really probably have to pay
for is just the property tax wow that's
beautiful
which is like you live in the other unit
yeah the third unit
that would be like i think i want to say
it was i calculated like 1600 bucks
which is way cheaper than what i'm
paying right now
so all that money that i could save then
i can maybe build something to
buy something yeah so that's like the
house hacking right where people
buy multi-units they live in one and
then they yeah
and if i would decide to leave based off
even just the numbers on 20
now like it cash flows which is very
rare around here but that's based off of
whatever the property is
priced at will it go over it i think it
could but with financing being cheaper i
was just calculating even for every like
100 thousand you go up
it was like 490 bucks a month wow right
which isn't changing a whole lot is your
client like hey three bedroom alhambra
how's that going man
it's my company i mean they're gonna
play cash and i i would probably have to
finance it you're going to compete with
them though right
i don't know we'll see hey dude guess
what dude that thing
nah you don't want it dude i heard
termites on the walls or some [ __ ]
door knobs are horrible how do you break
that to me let them know like hey if you
don't get it i'm going to get it type of
thing or
like yeah i'd probably definitely tell
them like the numbers are good for me
right now
really good i mean either way it's a win
right so but you can always find deals
it's just how patient you are it doesn't
happen overnight but you're going to
tell him that you're cutting him in line
no i haven't decided if i was actually
going to do it but i looked at
everything and i'm like this actually
seems numbers
too good pretty prominent so what would
be the reason for
someone to want a multi-unit it's an
investment property right it's rarely
an individual that wants to buy it for
their own place
yeah i think just securitizing like
later on down the future especially with
cash flow right i think your payments
are going to be fixed
for a certain period of time you can
your rents typically are going to go
up over time so you'll be able to cash
flow then you can build that equity
which is what we're talking about and
then those people tend to pull the money
out and then go buy something else i see
right so then you can start to build
build your wealth that way as well
and then the people that redid this
place
they were just looking to like fix it up
and sell it like they don't want the
responsibility of renting it out
no i think according to the agent when
she told me they were going to do it but
they decided
there was too much going on because i
mean they redid the whole thing which is
like
really it was it's really nice right um
i think it took them over like a year
and a half to fix
they're still gonna make money off of
the deal the sale yeah
um but the numbers still work can you
tell when somebody's not gonna be a
serious person like you you get all
kinds of people i bet being like
i just want to check out houses also i'm
not serious yeah so i think qualifying
in the beginning is probably going to be
the most critical part
like getting pre-approved getting
pre-approved if they don't want to get
people they're fighting me on that then
i know they're probably not going to be
that serious
especially in today's marketplace with
everything going so quickly it's like if
you want to keep looking i mean you can
look forever i mean i've
literally seen people look for like a
few years it's like
oh the market's going to change the
market's going yeah it's changing one
way that you
going up yeah yeah exactly so i think
you always have to just be ready
and i don't think there's a definite
period of when you're going to be ready
right and i don't think you can ever
time anything perfectly as well too so
just stick it long term and it's a real
estate it's always gonna be the same do
you break it to the mill you're like
you're not [ __ ] serious about this
yeah you're grounded by the [ __ ] i'm
not wasting my time in the in the
beginning i probably
could not figure that part out
i think now when i talk to the client up
front in that first
first meeting i know whether i can do it
or not or how long it's going to take
what about me so you know we're looking
for a house yeah we're looking for like
two years this guy bugs you how much
does he bug you well so the first one
was easy and then
yeah the first one was so easy but i
didn't look at any other house yeah we
looked at like getting this one
is that right and i'm like damn i think
you gave kevin free money right now yeah
the first one
the first one was relatively easy right
it was really easy yeah
the second one it's it happens very
often
with people in that situation where you
already have a house right you don't
have to there's no like
life urgency thing for you to have to do
it we look for
straight almost every or every weekend
almost every other weekend like three or
four months
but i mean i know you did i believe you
and i believe that you bugged the [ __ ]
of this poor guy
so for those of you he didn't even say
that he's like oh my god
he's like thank god he's moving nevada
but that's a rare case right that's it
dude how many hypotheticals
did you have to answer every day from
bart what if in this case
it's rare to have someone look at a
house for two years look how ready is
dude we [ __ ] got it
you guys got me um is it rare i mean
i probably had a few that i did that way
oh okay yeah well there's like really no
urgency
yeah yeah yeah that's true
[Music]
you